Our goal is to ensure that addressing the water crisis
becomes an integral part of global environmental strategy.
We have gathered at a time when the world
is experiencing an unprecedented
global crisis in its development model.
The water crisis is an integral part
of the general crisis and,
above all, the crisis of world politics.
The problem is exacerbated by climate change.
Access to water is becoming
a source of international conflicts.
80% of infectious diseases are caused
by the use of poor-quality water.
In developing countries,
about 95% of all surface water is polluted.
In the European Union, 37 children die every day
from water-related diseases.
Unfortunately, the policy response
has been slow in the face
of this emergency.
If it continues, tomorrow it will be too late.
I believe that all of us, including Europe,
are responsible for the current situation.
Europe deserves credit:
during a difficult decade,
it has taken the lead
in the efforts to develop
a new global environmental agenda.
We should formalise the idea that water,
as the most important human resource,
is common property
and access to it
should be proclaimed
a fundamental human right.
I hope that our discussion will become a contribution
to the current research on which,
without exaggeration,
the future of mankind will depend.
Thank you for your attention.